hello my name is offline patrocian and
today i'm going to be discussing the
extracellular matrix and renal
development in cancer
just a brief background about the extra
stellar matrix
the extracellular matrix is highly
complex it is composed of both physical
signals such as fibronectin laminate and
collagen
and is also made up of soluble signals
such as growth factors cytokines and
chemokines
we also have integrands which are
transmembrane proteins that directly
link the actin cytoskeleton with the
extracellular matrix to transmit signals
bi-directionally
between the extras matrix and the
cytoplasmic domain
and this is to promote salivation and
recognition during embryogenesis
homeostasis tissue repair immune
response
and metastatic diffusion of tumor cells
and this is an important concept because
in cancer
the extracellular matrix actually plays
a huge role
for example in breast cancer in normal
mammary glands
we have the basement membrane made up of
laminates and collagen four and we also
have the interstitial
extracellular matrix composed of liberal
collagens such as one
three and four uh also fibronectin
however when we have breast cancer uh we
actually have a disruption of this
basement membrane
and we could have a decreased uh
deposition of collagen four
and laminate one mean one or uh also
fibronectin
membrane and we could have a decrease uh
that position
yeah can you hear me
[Music]
hello
okay
um
uh tyler can you hear me
yes can you hear me yes i i might have
opened some other
web browser and i think it kept
recording i don't know it was playing
back whatever
we started all over yes that seems to
have been the case um so
what slide were you on
i was on slide number two
okay if you'd like we can go ahead and
just start fresh from the beginning
yes i i would prefer we start from fresh
okay let's go ahead and do that um let
me go ahead and make a
quick editing note and then we can get
started again
okay
okay all set so just go ahead and give
it a few seconds of silence and then you
can start again
hello my name is oswick patrician and
today i will be discussing the
extracellular matrix and renal
development in cancer
a brief background about the extra
stellar matrix uh the extracellular
matrix is composed of physical signals
such as fibronectin laminate and
collagen
and it's also composed of soluble
sickness such as growth factors
cytokines and chemokines
we also have integrands which are
transmembrane proteins that link the
actin cytoskeleton with the
extracellular matrix
to transmit signals bi-directionally
between the extracellular matrix and
cytoplasmic domains and they did this to
promote cellulation and recognition
during development homeostasis and
disease processes
in particular the extracellular matrix
also plays a role in cancer
for example in
normal mammary glands we have the
basement membrane which is composed of
laminates collagen
four and also the interstitial
extracellular matrix which is composed
of fabric collagen
such as type 1 3 and 4 and fibronectin
however when we have cancer we actually
have a destruction of this basement
membrane
and we see a decrease in collagen 4 and
laminin 1 1
1 and while we see an increase in ecm
remodeling
mmps we also see a stiffer interstitial
extracellular matrix with more
deposition of fibril collagen
one three and four and fibronectin so
this brings into an important concept
the fact that we need to be able to
characterize the extracellular matrix of
cancer
in order to develop newer innovative
treatments specifically designed to
target specific
parts of the cancer such as cancer stem
cells and in a way to reduce the risk of
reoccurrence and metastasis i will also
be discussing the kidney
and here's a brief background about the
kidney the kidney is highly complex and
it has multiple functions
the functional unit of the kidney is
called the nephron
and one of the functions of the kidney
is to filter our blood and blood
filtration
occurs within the glomerulus as shown by
the pointed arrow
we also have a beautiful schematic
image of the kidney extracellular matrix
in particular
the nephron and we could see that
depending on the location of the nephron
you have different
deposition of ecm proteins for example
in the glomerulus
uh the glomerular basement membrane uh
has to have the deposition of collagen
for
alpha three four and five however when
we have mutation
within any of these chains we have
something called alkerson trump
and unfortunately patients with alpha
syndrome they have decreased kidney
function and eventually we'll need a
transplant
so this brings a important point that we
do
have a characterization of the ecm of
the adult
nephron in particular however little is
known about the extracellular matrix and
renal development
and that's what we wanted to do and
that's to characterize the extracellular
matrix
in fetal development and here we have a
histology
of fetal kidney at 10 16 and 20 weeks
uh an h e and a picoseries red where the
red denotes the deposition of collagen
and we could see that over time there
are changes that occur
from 10 weeks to 20 weeks from a to c
we see that in fact we have a reduction
of the nephrogenic
zone we see presence of more developed
structures
of the nephron such as glomeruli
vasculature and tubules
we also see increased lobes and we also
see
distinguishable architectural structures
of the kidneys such as the renal pelvis
medulla and the cortex
and looking at the picoseries red and e
and f we could see from d
to f that we have more complex and
organized deposition of
ecm and this is quite important for
the function of the chain moving forward
we also wanted to look at the
particular fibrous proteins uh such as
collagens
fibronectin and laminin alpha 5 and
we've done
a same immunofluorescent staining at 10
weeks shown in
a c e g and i k m and o
and a 20 weeks staining shown in
the rest and what we could see that over
time
we do see changes in the distribution of
fractions of matrix
expressed for example for fibronectin in
a
and b at 10 weeks we see the deposition
of fibromyalgia throughout
the fetal kidney however at 20 weeks we
can see more specification
mostly in the cortex of the kidney we
also see the same thing
for collagen 16 shown in k
and l where at 10 weeks and k we see
distribution of collagen sticking
throughout the fetal kidney
however in l at 20 weeks we really see a
specification mostly within the renal
cortex specifically the nephrogenic zone
and we see also for collagen for alpha
one and two
shown in dna that wasn't initially a g
in developing around developing
structures but at age it seems to
specify mostly within the glomerulus
so we believe this enhanced organization
expression of the ecm
might actually be dictating cell
differentiation versus
staminas so what we wanted to do
is look into the nephron progenitors the
nether progenitors
uh actually give rise to the full mature
nephron
uh they are identifiable by
transcription factor six two and sided
one shown in the red arrow
they're found within the kappa
mesenchyme and they interact with the
eurotaric but and over time they create
uh they are induced to differentiate
they make developing structures such as
renal vessel comma shape
shaped body and they eventually formed
the full mature nephron
and most of the studies done on these uh
progerian population
have been more focused on intracellular
events
more molecular studies and what we see
what we wanted to do was actually
characterize the extracellular matrix
and hope to identify ways that the
extracellular matrix
might promote their stemness rather than
their differentiation and also their
motility survival
and so our aim was to characterize the
extracellular matrix within
these nephron progenitors in normal
human developing kidney
and also identify how extracellular
matrix
might be promoting their self-renewal
versus differentiation
and we wanted to use the information
that we obtained from this
to actually apply it in vitro for us to
be able to culture these cells for an
extended period of time
so here's a immunofluorescent staining
of a 10-week fetal kidney
that identifies these nephron
progenitors 6-2
identified by uh red cited one in green
and dabbing showing nuclear stainings
and we could see that
the expression of these markers are in
the nephrogenic zone in the outer layer
and inner lobes of the kidney and we can
see that
over time um initially
around the keples again they have strong
expression of six to one cyto one but
once they make the developing structures
such as the renal vessel
c shape and comet shaped body they begin
to lose the expression of cyto one
and six two and once they make the full
mature nephron
they do not have the expression of these
markers
so in normal development
nephron progenitor should disappear
before or soon after birth
however in some cases this per general
population are left behind
and this gives rise to womb's tumor
womb's tumor is a pediatric cancer
also known as nephroblastoma and it
accounts for 95
of renal malignancies in children it's
quite rare it occurs one in ten thousand
to one in eight thousand children
and one tumor is believed to originate
from abnormal renal development
and tends to histologically resemble
fetal developmental stages
not found in postnatal mature functional
kidneys
so our goal was to characterize the
extracellular matrix within
normal developed uh nephron progenitors
and wounds tumor nephron virginities
that also expressed sticks to one side
of one
and here's an uh immunofluorescent
staining the 10-week human fetal kidney
showing the expression of six two-sided
one found
in their proper location in the kappa
mesenchyme
while on the right we have a stage three
womb summer of a six month old patient
and we could see again the deposition of
this per general population that should
not be
present moving forward to have a
bigger grasp on the extent of these per
german population
it varies from tumor to more but in
particular we see an extensive
expression of six to sight of one within
the worm tumor
and not in a proper organized manner as
we saw
within the fetal kidney in fact most of
the
expression of 1671 is found within the
blasphemy
and we these are the most
undifferentiated portion of the tumor
however once the tumor attempts to
differentiate and create a board of
structures such as tubules
and glomeruli they lose the expression
of 627 and also the stroma does not have
a strong expression of these markers
so next what we wanted to do just to
grasp a general concept
was to look at the extracellular matrix
composition of the worms tumor first we
wanted to look at this
histology and we did again h e and
picoseries red staining
and we could see that unlike the human
fetal kidney it is a disorganized
mesh of cells and in particular this
tumor had a lot of blastoma
that is why it has a lot of these
uncharacterized structures and moving
forward we wanted to look at the
extracellular matrix proteins that we
have looked for the human field kidney
and what we could tell is yes it is a
disorganized expression
occurs however we distinguish that the
strong expression
of laminin alpha 5 cauldron 16 and to
some extent collagen 221 and cauldron 18
is mostly found within the blastomole
component
while expression of fibronectin collagen
1 3
and 4 alpha 102 is found more in the
tumor interstitium
so next we wanted to look at actually
the nephrogenic progenitors uh the
nephron progenitors their niche
so we looked at normal human fetal
kidney uh
which is identified a through h and also
loom sumer
plastema i2p and we could see
the eurotaric blood beautifully outlined
by collagen 18 and collagen one
shown in e and b and the outer portion
where
we have the nephron progenitors and in
the blessed neural
component is the most undifferentiated
component so it's a
mass of cells and what we could identify
is that indeed the human fetal kidney
nephron progenitors and the woman's
tumor nephron progenitors share similar
extracellular matrix characteristics
they express collagen 16
identifiable in f and n
and laminin alpha 5 identifiable in h
and p and to some extent collagen 18
identifiable in
e and m uh well
we see that the lumps tumor net from
progenitor appear to have
less expression of collagen 21
identified in g
in human fetal kidney and o in the
womb's tumor
so this gave us a little bit of
information
next we wanted to know even further so
we wanted to
actually do single cell analysis on
these for general population because we
know heterogeneity does exist
within these population so what we had
done
previously we were able to isolate these
per general populations based on the
transcription factor six two sided one
and we did this by using smartphone
technology rna probes
and we've published this data before and
we wanted to do the same thing with the
womb's tumor
and see if we could also obtain one
tumor in the comfort general population
and we were indeed able to do the same
and
one important thing to note is in the
human fetal kidney the percentage zero
six two zeter one
uh was pretty consistent however in the
womb's tumor depending on the tumor type
and stage uh we actually had differences
in expression
of six to seven one this particular
tumor which were predominantly more
plastema
had actually 51 percent expression of
six suicidal one
next we just wanted to look in bulk uh
if we see a difference between the human
fetal kidney and the tumors
so we use three different tumors uh loom
tumor number three which is unfavorable
one summer number four which is
favorable
and one summer number five which was
classified as favorable however it was a
stage four
and the patient received treatment so
these cells have received no
uh therapy treatment and we wanted to
compare it to hemophilia kidney in our
previous publication
uh which were around uh 17 weeks of
gestation
as we could see that the human fetal
kidneys more clustered together and
they're very similar to each other while
the wound swimmer
there seems to be variation between too
much tumor
and we know this does exist and next we
wanted to just look
closer into the extracellular matrix and
we looked at collagen
and we could see that the womb tumors
tend to cluster more chores
together while the human fetal kidney
cluster together
and they share similar similarities
between one another
while laminin it seemed like they
actually
expressed similar laminates and in
particular they
expressed a lot of lamin and alpha phi
we also wanted to look at
integrins and again the women's tumor
appeared to cluster more together and
human fetal
things cluster more together but one
important thing to note is
that there was a statistically
significant difference
in the expression of integrand beta 1.
in fact
integral and beta 1 appeared to be
highly expressed within the human fetal
kidney compared to the womb tumor
so we thought this was interesting
because uh there's a lot of information
on integral beta 1
and it's important in development
maintaining stem cell stemness
and also promoting cancer
so we wanted to confirm this so we did
immunofluorescence
stainings of human fetal kidneys shown
on the
left panel uh for instagram beta 1
and 62 shown in red and integrand
beta 1 and cited 1 shown in green and we
compared it to the human fetal kidney
uh for the same stainings and we could
see that indeed there seems to be a
higher expression
of integrand beta one where we find um
these progenitor cells compared to the
tumor
in fact there seems to be a higher
expression of integral beta 1
by the uroteric but also by whom summer
developing structures shown
on the right below where we have tubular
structure and they are strongly
expressing integram
1. so we confirmed that in the
hemophilia condition and from vagina
show stronger expression of insulin beta
1 compared to the womb's tumor so this
is interesting
next we wanted to actually look at it at
a single cell level
and we wanted to identify if this was
also the case so what we did is
we isolated one seminar from progenitors
human fetal candida from progenitors
and we did single cell analysis on them
and then we merged the data and we
wanted to identify clusters shared
solely
uh by wound seminar from progenitors and
only by hemophilicating them from
progenitors and some clusters shared
together
and what we identified was indeed there
was two clusters
that were shared by human fetal kidney
and one supernatural progenitors which
were clusters number two and seven
but we were able to identify six
clusters
that were mostly expressed by womb's
tumor now from progenitors
we also identified four clusters that
were solely expressed by human fetal
kidney from progenitors
so next we wanted to test if indeed
the expression of collagen's laminates
and integrands within the clusters
interestingly enough we identified that
indeed
the clusters identified one sumer
nephron progenitors predominantly
shown in red and in red boxes tend to
cluster together
and they had much lower expression of
collagens
and integrands specifically instagram
beta 1
shown by the arrow while clusters uh
mostly expressed by human fetal candida
from progenitors appear to have
stronger expression of extracellular
matrix
proteins and clusters shared by boat
uh seem to have stronger expression
compared to human
wounds tumor nephron for joiners only
clusters but
one of the clusters so they share two
clusters one of the cluster did
in fact have expression of integral beta
1 that the other cluster did not
so in general uh we also see that the
shared clusters had higher expression of
collagen 16
shown in arrow and also collagen 6.
so in general what we could take from
this is that they all express
lamin and alpha five shown in the arrow
and from the middle to some extent uh
while the wound sumina from progenitors
appear to have much less expression of
instagram beta 1. next we wanted to
test if this low expression of integram
beta 1
and expression of lamin and alpha 5
might be
important in maintaining uh their
self-renewal
rather than because these cells are left
behind and they're unable to
differentiate
and they keep maintaining the expression
of six to sighted one and we wanted to
use laminin 511 for 11 and alpha 5 and
we know that integral beta 1
and laminar 511 do interact together
so we what we did is in vitro cultures
of normal nephron progenitors and we
tested out different culture conditions
in particular we
tested for a tissue culture without any
cleaning
and the cells do not like this and they
tend to not be able to attach
we tested metri gel which is the
standard currently to culture these
cells on nutri gel
and collagen 1 fiber next in collagen 16
and lamin and 511
and we tested through full analysis for
the expression of
6-2 and cited 1. after five days
what we see uh that laminate 511
when the cells were cultured on
laminar501 they seem to
maintain the expression of six two-sided
one significantly compared to all the
other cultural conditions
and next we wanted to see what if we
lock
integrand beta 1 using anti-instagram
beta 1 antibodies
and with this change that made
expression of 62 cyto1
and indeed with flow analysis we showed
that in standard case using dimitri gel
we have a little bit about 20
maintenance after 28 days of culture
uh f in laminin a little bit more
while when we block instagram beta 1
uh and culture distills on laminate 511
we are able to maintain their expression
of six two-sided one significantly
up to almost eighty percent in some
cases
and this correlates to the wound super
nephron progenitors
cultured on just laminate so they are
unable to differentiate
uh well so they maintain their
expression of 671
so they're very similar this brings us
to
the summary basically what we find that
wound sumana from progenitors and human
fetal candida from progenitors
express similar acm markers such as
collagen 16 collagen 21 and laminate
alpha 5
and this may be important to regulate
their self renewal rather than their
differentiation we also see with the
single cell rna seq data
the cluster mostly expressed by human
fetal candida from progenitors have
higher expression collagen
laminates and triggers compared to
clusters mostly expressed by one seminar
from progenitors
we also see that clusters shared by will
sumer and hemophilia canina from
progenitors
shows stronger expression of collagen 16
and collagen alpha six as
collagen sticks alpha one and causing
six alpha one is known to have a broad
range of cytoprotective effects and it
has a role in
maintaining stemness and also
in cancer we also see that lung sumana
from progenitors and hemophilia
necromancers both express
laminin 501 and collagen 16 constantly
and cluster predominantly ex expressed
by womb similar from progenitors
show very low expression of instagram
beta 1.
so we can promote uh
we find that we can promote in vitro
human fetal network
and stop renewal versus their
differentiation by mimicking the woman's
tumor nephron progenitor extracellular
matrix
niche by using a vitro coating of
laminin 501 and blockage of integrand
beta 1.
and final thoughts are that we should
consider that the role of the ecm
extends beyond mechanics
and the local ecm environment is highly
self-specific
we by studying um
in cancer stem cell biology and
by studying and understanding and
characterizing the extracellular matrix
and cancer we could actually find ways
to provide more
novel therapeutic targets or stem cells
and understand why they stay in the
self-renewal state rather than they
differentiate um and we could do this by
looking at the human fetal kidney now
from progenitors and comparing to the
womb's tumor
nephron progenitors so currently
we are looking to have new tools and new
technologies constantly
uh we could uh characterize the
extracellular matrix in different ways
such as quantitative proteomics
we can do deceleration and we also have
large data sets now that we could rely
on and
go into and identify what the
extracellular matrix composition should
be for each organ
so with that in mind i would like to
thank my pi dr
also dr de saco who's a co who's a co-pi
on this project
and my also dr aguilari and
viliani who also worked with me on this
project
and of course that we are the gopher
foundation and
without the go for our foundation we
weren't we wouldn't be where we are and
our foundation and also all the um
awards that we have received in the past
with that um
thank you
okay i'm done okay awesome job
uh well we're all set um
we're pretty much from here uh we'll
just do some quick editing on the front
and back ends and get your presentation
ready for the event in a few weeks
okay great was i talking really quickly
i tend to talk pretty fast sometimes no
i um
i didn't think so i thought that you
communicated uh smoothly and clearly
okay perfect thank you awesome
um well any questions for me before we
wrap up here
um no well one thing would i be able to
see the final version
before you send it out definitely i can
send out a
preview link once we've completed the
editing
okay that's great thank you of course
well if any questions come up feel free
to reach out but if not i will send you
that preview link once it's ready
okay awesome thank you tyler have a
great weekend
you too bye-bye